[Music]
now
[Music]
at the first show i did at the resident
i asked the crowd i was like
yeah i was like just talking about some
things and i was like
who here actively
shits on capitalism and specifically
billionaires online
but but you're in the closet about
wanting to become a billionaire and then
this kid everyone
like seven of them kept their hands up i
was like yeah
[Laughter]
billionaires are bad except if it was me
i'd be a really good billionaire yeah no
i would buy cool stuff i would be i
would buy an actual nice house yeah if i
was a billionaire i wouldn't buy those
stupid lamp shades i said this on twitch
and someone asked me what would you do
as a billionaire i was like i would
delete arby's i'd have enough money to
do that
yeah i'd get rid of arby's then who who
would have the meats
um
that's arby's right we got the meats
yeah their slogan yeah who would have
the meats though if arby's gone well ice
gone i think that phrase is misleading
because what they have is roast beef and
no one needs that
yeah who actually eats roast beef like
besides on christmas oh here's another
thing i'd do i would take all the
spicy wendy's nuggets and i would trick
everyone and make them vegan oh that's
evil but everyone be eating like oh my
and i'd make wendy's free
hmm
you like wendy's
wendy city wendy's
congrats on the million what else are
you gonna do
um i'd buy myself a boat
yeah there you go
yeah everyone what would you do for your
billionaire everyone's like well i would
probably try and solve the homeless
christ come on what would you actually
do i'd buy a boat yeah yeah yeah i buy a
how many billion how many billion how
many billions do i have one i buy one
billion dollar boat
it'd be a sick boat yeah not enough to
staff it nothing just about it's staying
docked and it's just gonna rot there
rough cost
see that's what i'd buy he's a
billionaire
nice what would you what would you buy
you have two billion
two billion
two boats
yeah you saw that tick
yes yeah i did
we should probably talk about that i
didn't know mormons had threesomes yeah
that's the old mormon threesome i guess
i guess you call that you don't have to
be mormon to do that you know what i'm
saying yeah like you could still have a
mormon threesome yeah that's kind of the
missionary position why do they call it
missionary like
is it cause
is it like you're trying to hide it
from the priest or something i don't
know that's
that's not how i meant it if you don't
know what the soaking thing it like
describe it for people who haven't seen
it yeah yeah yeah that's that's probably
important i just assume everyone's seen
this so basically
uh you know there's like a stereotype
that mormons perform a
um
what is it
a sex what's like the term for a sexual
action before marriage
like adult like out of wedlock out of
wedlock you [ __ ] put your penis in
someone's vagina you don't move you know
that's not sex sex is when you
like rub your channels against each
other yeah but you just soak it yeah
like a like a log
in a river
soaking yeah it's not sex no
but it's also not sex
if someone
like your friend
jumps on the bed
repeatedly
so that it does end up you know rubbing
against each other but it's not that
you're not doing it so yeah it's not
saying yeah like it's not swimming if
you dip your toe in the water and you
leave it there for like 10 minutes
until you got to pull your toe out
because it's going to start spitting i
don't know it's so funny though that one
the original tick tock when it's like
that girl that was like when you got to
be a wingman for your mormon friend so
you jump on the bed and and i was like
reading this couch like what what
oh my god what is she what are you
talking about jumping on the bed oh
because
the dude's like
little little left
faster like they're both
dirty talking but like to the girl who's
jumping on the bed yeah
yeah faster faster fast all slower slow
down
[Laughter]
the girls like faster dude slower she's
like i don't know what the [ __ ] to do
you guys are telling me opposing things
she just starts jumping at an awkward
pace to the point and then just like
her legs come up and then the bed goes
down and then she stands up straight and
the bed springs back and just inverts
her kneecaps it just breaks both her
legs
faster slower faster slower
oh my god
i'm picturing like another person on the
bed and they're like double bouncing
them you know
yeah
they're going high as [ __ ]
they're soaking with their they're
popping three feet off the bed they're
out it's like [ __ ] out
it's like that guarding me with that
person sleeping in the air
exactly there's two people floating in
it's just rotating in space
extreme soaking do you think your dick
can prune
definitely dude that's exactly what i
think when i think of soaking
yeah it sounds so uncomfortable
yeah pull that [ __ ] out it's an
overcooked hot dog oh man
completely soft yeah you pull it out
it's just a little raisin i'm dying
laughing at like the idea of a dude
laying on top and he's like should we
call
should we call jocelyn in here to jump
around
yeah and then
they're like kind of like giddy about it
and they're like all right just not too
strong she's like okay and just one
bounce he's like i'm done
dude no it's just from her climbing on
the bed yeah he climbs on the bed in
just that moment he goes
thank you
wait i haven't even started jumping yet
i have to call my mom
if you nut from that process
[Laughter]
like man like explaining that explaining
that is so much worse than
everyone around you is just looking at
you like you should have just [ __ ]
like
like imagine her getting pregnant too
that's what i'm saying she's like like
pre-marriage and everyone in her
family's like what the [ __ ] and she's
like no we didn't [ __ ]
we soak bounce
[Laughter]
immaculate conception mom
it's a miracle yeah
literally no pumps required
just the smallest shift and you're just
oh no go slower go slower go slower i
don't even know how you have the
patience for soaking
i mean what else what do you do
what else do you do like you talk do you
talk no no i'm saying like what do you
do when you're soaking
you just look at each other do you kiss
or just nose to nose looking at each
other yeah do you have your t-shirts on
that's weird as hell if you have shirts
on yeah
yeah
just like winnie the pooh just
t-shirts on socks on yeah and the pants
aren't even all the way off they're just
rolled down yeah
yeah looks like you're both taking the
[ __ ] on each other just
yeah yeah yeah what do you do
talk about
yeah maybe just talk and then
hopefully you don't let it all go
you